max scherzer the 251 er8 that's the best
of his career we're talking about a guy
who's won three cy youngs 37 years old
and hasn't lost the step and he really
has gained a step since becoming a
dodger they have enjoyed having him on
the mound the price they paid to get him
here has really paid off and this is why
you get the big game picture this is the
night when you can step forward and get
into first place and you can continue a
hot streak well max scherzer is the man
for the job peterson leading things off
and striking out on three pitches good
morning good afternoon good night to
start scherzer's night the hometown kid
max free jeff is going to work against
the dodgers tonight and the last four
road starts you see three and one under
a one era
last five starts he's pouring out with a
136 so peaking at the right time max
muncie 258 hitter seven career home runs
against the braves
once he drives above the left center
field rosario's back on it it's gone
home run max muncie
30th of the season for muncie and the
dodgers lead one nothing out over the
plate and max doesn't do too much with
it he just muncies it out of here
there's travis darno to lead it all
pulled down the line
and caught and she's in the dodger
jersey one gone
nice play
aliana will be signing autographs by the
end of the night scherzer whines kicks
delivers the payoff swing in a missed
strike three got him to chase a slider
well strikeout number two
for max scherzer that slider just
continues to go especially when he stays
on top of it
that ball just got barely the outside
corner now adam duvall coming up cavalla
223 he's got 29 home runs and 88 runs
batted in here he
comes a change-up feathered over the
inside corner to strike him out third
strikeout for scherzer and the braves
are gone in order in the second
back shoes are cruising along so far
back to the top for peterson
who they are calling the blonde bomber
change up he went around strike three
serves who's gotten him both times
another one two three inning on 10
pitches austin barnes five home runs 19
runs batted in 3-2
and a fly ball hit to deep left field
austin barnes gets it gone
two nothing on a barn solo shot all run
number six for barnes on the season
barnes second home run in his last three
games he had one against the padres top
of the fourth inning max scherzer back
up on top of the hill facing the
shortstop dansby swanson not only is he
a mystery or what he's going to throw
you
in the beginning of the count in the
middle of the count he's a mystery in
how he's going to put you away
like that perfect example yeah and that
bad he goes fastball slider change
gets him on three pitches fifth of the
game here's freeman who muscled the only
hit of the game
wow
it's one of the great hitters in
baseball down on three pitches flailing
wildly
six strikeouts for scherzer and he's
retired eight in a row adam duvall
walking up to home plate now dodgers
will shift three to the left even with a
runner at first
fastball for strike three duvalic a
house by the side of the road watches it
blaze by and schrozer has his seventh a
fastball is a put away pitch two down
and two on so the tying runs on base and
the pitcher max freed coming up
produces his eighth strike out of the
ninth through five
here's dance me with one out
one two strike three call a fastball
right down the middle knee-high taken by
swanson two out the way he is attacking
he's got everything working he's got the
power he's got the finesse scherzer has
set it up for the bullpen the dodgers
turned things over to hard-throwing
right-hander brewstar gradual let's see
if the braves can get something started
against him tying run at the plate in
the form of eddie rosario's at seven
home runs all those come in
in cleveland
and that one is hit high in the air left
center field and deep at the wall
rosario ties it up
freed off the hook scherzer can't win it
braves have new life and the blue birds
are out at dodger stadium it's two to
two
well i'll tell you why i think the blue
birds are out i think the blue birds are
mad that
dave roberts took out max scherzer in
this ball game
02 fastball
that's what i'm saying no matter if you
throw 100 these guys can time it up with
corey seeger and his
tendency to swing at the first pitch who
knows what corey will get this is
bobblehead night
and he hits the high drive to deep
center field corey zieger
caught at the wall
oh my goodness
that
close
as we try to snap it over three he
struck out his last two trips
dansby cracks one to center and deep
that ball is deep that ball is gone
that one deep enough
dansby swanson puts atlanta in front
it's a 3-2 game one thing we know about
dansby his power i'm telling you right
center is a
massive strength for him and he just
showed it there to give the braves a
lead his 26th homer
and now mookie bets over threes punched
out three times which is unusual in its
own right here's a 2-2 and he's down on
strikes for the fourth time tonight
his first four strikeout game since his
first full year in the majors in 2015.
you go up and away first time they've
done that all night you can see how
mookie is just not expecting it and
almost feeling for the ball out there
runner at third two gone and a 3-2 game
in the eighth and chris martin is on to
face justin turner
[Music]
[Applause]
justin turner comes through
clutch and he hit it in a hole between
third and short
the one run in a 3-3 ball game go ahead
run into scoring position and it's
pollock coming up
ground ball based at left field here
comes justin turner there is no throw
they take the lead
for the second night in a row they get
it done in the bottom of the eighth joe
kelly trying to lock down a 4-3 win and
dubal hits a slow ground ball to third
charged by turner he's up with the
throws to first that's the ball game and
the dodgers sweep the braves and pull
into a first place tie for the moment
with the giants
all even atop the standings pending the
outcome
of the game
in san francisco joe kelly his fifth
career save
and aj pollock with the game-winning rbi
tonight
you